my ice cream like chocolate I like pizza
and cheese like a dude is hurt ain't
dance night dance Steven I just got
dance oh my god
[Music]
worst fire team ever destiny to her you
have been Wow yeah we're already on
seven men and then now today thankfully
we get to talk about our destiny to
review everybody didn't want to hear
that fantabulous even me and Griffin it
us no just people want to hear about the
destiny so yeah so let's talk about it
so uh who wants to start out what do you
guys think I think it's great I didn't
like it at first and that stupid beta
those dumb guns but now it's great you
know but I know the DLC is coming out
and it needs to come out cuz I'm already
like yeah bored bored I mean I don't
want to say bored but yes bored are we
bored because it's like you know it's
like you know what's funny is built and
boringness and destiny like you know how
you going at you doing a public event
and then even she says they're doing
their cash again like they've even built
into the game that they know we're doing
the same [ __ ] over and over and over and
over again but I like the challenges I
like grabbing stuff I think the I think
the rewards should be better mm-hmm
it's more checklist II you don't want it
to be yeah right but I think that the
reward should be better like they used
to be like you know this feeling of like
you would do another thing and you you
wouldn't get a legendary or anything and
then when so then the off chance that
you did get it you'd be like I got a
legend it now you are you you're gonna
get a legendary every time yes you're
building up this coin right in grams or
yeah yeah that Brian grand [ __ ] it
always ruins the yeah I wish they meant
more I wish the Brighton gram because
you kind of go oh man so I got some
shaders and a ship maybe mod welcome to
ever verse what I do like about the
bright Ingraham though no the whole
reason they did that is just because
people were were bitching about the the
the pay to play like pong to get content
that other people don't get that's the
soul right right so like without paying
you can get it through actual gameplay
which I'm all for as
or like you said the repetitive of the
legendary and stuff like that I just
think the biggest issue which hopefully
they're addressing is the weapon mods
right I was just about to bring that
[ __ ] up yeah that [ __ ] sucks you can see
how you got a banshee and it's like you
guys don't you don't tell me how to get
those he was like you just dismantled
the blue ones to get it and I know that
you have to do this mental to
Legendary's to get it to get that sorry
oh dude that's kind of that it's kind of
like too broad it's not specific because
I don't get it either
you have to buy I know a legendary mark
I don't either and the thing is it's
like and then your glimmer it's like
5,000 just do one thing it takes a lot
so so all I'll try to give a little
recap of how to do so like him so like
normally we would tell Steve this when
we're playing but he can't play anymore
because I don't even know he existed
anymore he's gonna be touching yeah yeah
the Steve's actually here everybody his
balls aren't but she's got him in a
permanent shadow should be twice how the
mods work is when you get like three of
a blue mod it'll give you the option to
buy the legendary version you get one of
them so so that's on so when you get
three of one blue mod so the same on the
same mod you get a say you can buy a
legendary killer damage right and it
doesn't cost any glimmer you'll that
those are the ones you see at the bottom
of banshee know when they pop up is the
low that's because you have three
replicants of the blue of the same
that was random oh [ __ ] like that makes
it even worse though that makes it even
more like that's what I'm saying there's
no casino element well that's taken out
getting three blue mods is not quick Wow
those come in the Brighton rooms right
no no the blue well sometimes but
usually the blue magis you you'll get
them as drops or those that's a problem
cuz I'm dismantling him before that
happens
- you're dismantling yeah well alright
so no but even still that's still hard
to get three blue yeah but here you can
buy but that usually a glimmer so
there's there's just say one thing I get
it like you you can buy The blue mods
you run out of glimmer but that's why
you play you play to get glimmer to
Barcia but there's also a trick right
because we're all sitting on a bunch of
legendary shards so what people have
been doing is using their legendary
shards to buy the exotics the like you
know any exotic because you can get them
for the legendary marks weight and
weight from xur from sir
no no like you know when you go to the
ball and the if you've got the exotic
before and you can you can buy it again
you can buy that exotic again for like
10 legendary they did it in Destiny one
you can always read birdie balls excited
yeah what what do you mean the
blueprints yeah
so what they do now is like if for
whatever reason you got rid of the
exotic you got that you got the
blueprint so if you've got it
you can spend ten legendary marks to to
get to buy a new one I did not know
store your ship move the blue because
they moved their collections letting go
to the collection remember the blueprint
yeah that's what I'm saying because
everybody has we need to Xbox okay right
bumper right bumper right bumper and you
you can get the exotics and what it
because what it does you buy the exotic
right you got a bunch of legendary mark
so you can buy a bunch of exotics
dismantle them because you get gunsmith
materials when you dismantle the weapon
so then when you turn in the gunsmith
materials and you get a package he gives
you mods he gives his blue mods so you
don't have to spend Limor you can get
mods from just dismantling the exotics
and then taking the weapon parts back
that's [ __ ] that's a glitch right well
let's go back to I mean okay aside from
how you get the legendary mods let's go
back to what you do or don't like about
destiny too so like how all the weapons
are the same yeah the grinding elements
I don't like that unlike a different
roles yeah it's like you should be able
to get like like everybody's using
Uriel's gifts right everyone but it
should be like you should be like there
should be ten different types and like
somebody got a god role or somebody got
like you know well commander I got
around yeah but they're all this is a
barrel but the thing - even with the
armor even with the armor it's all the
same like you look on your inventory and
you go ok I have three of these I know
exactly what it is I just get rid of
these I just want that I don't think you
should be like that I think I like the
idea like you got like oh I got this
special yeah it was harder to keep track
of can you be like alright especially
with like you know you you have like
alright solar so I have to have four
pieces of solar to make my episode I
solar guy better so it's gonna be more
than keep track of but that's the fun of
yeah
yeah it's like you have something to
shoot for hung onto that [ __ ] for being
really good 45 minutes later yeah so
what are we getting the front door Frank
you were talking about grinding though
so like that's a good point where
there's not really like there's not a
big rind anymore
no what's it doing you guys remember it
like even even me the only PvE I would
do at the end of Destiny one was that
undying mine strike because I'm looking
for a God role mago loop so like I don't
my my motivation
yeah my kind of motivation to do PvE is
kind of lacking and that that's another
thing I feel like they need to bring it
like a strike a specific loop back and
stuff like that just don't even play
strikes and you know but I got nobody
strikes remember how that they know they
had the challenges and you know so
everything they'll have those like
specific director challenges right if
you go to any planet at any time and you
pressed one of that one button it'll
show you like some some some challenges
that you could do it every time yeah
left trigger yeah in a in a key coming
and they keep coming all the time but I
know they're not left trigger left
triggers in director know when you go to
the planet oh okay and you're in the
middle of playing oh there's three
milestones like lost sector yeah yeah
hold right right right right
but that loop should be better so like
only the only thing that's like random
is like when you get a exotic Engram
yeah that's like you don't know when
that's coming well Graham the bright
Engram too because that weapon anytime
but no it doesn't have to bar that's but
what else the bar filled up before you
got those now you just got motes of
light most of floats away what happened
a prison of elders man alright so well I
just want to go back to the woman mind
yeah so like this is I think what
they're doing with this next next
expansion I know but I don't want to get
into the next expansion because we gonna
well it's not necessarily what in the
next expansion I'm just saying what they
should have done from the beginning yeah
the problem is what he said it doesn't
like about yeah this is what I'm saying
don't like so like the armor mods I'm
cool with it because they they each you
know they give different abilities for
your character so like resilience or
recharging your grenade faster or you
know stuff like that so you you got that
but the weapons don't have any abilities
you just get a kinetic mod or or element
based yeah so there's no month so if I
understand what they want to do for the
the fixed roles they brought fixed roles
back because they don't want that unfair
gun they don't want people getting that
God role and it just has an advantage
over everybody that's what they don't
want
they're kind of taking a page to hit but
you look at everybody the same good
alright that's what what would exactly
what so they don't give variety in
weapon yeah stats that everyone Ananda
see a hundred thousand might a
multi-tool and then Uriel's gift which
that's what I said
it's easier to it's easier to find the
meta and that's what I said but that
what their argument is they don't want
those few people having a ridiculously
powered gun that and other people can't
get they would rather have a powerful
gun that everybody can get which I don't
like because I don't like you know the
thing of the meta Griffon have sorry my
mic is like got its own it looks like
it's on top of the court it is because I
can't a my headphones keep
cutting in and out I can't run out her
so when I have like a certain angle it
like you know dangle yeah anyway but but
but uh but so I see that but a way they
could find it like they could fit it
right in the middle they could keep the
fixed roles and then have weapon mods
that actually give you a perch so I get
to pick one person that I want to put on
this gun I just say something about the
might and all that I think one problem
is like even if the miters like the meta
there why not multiple metas like you
said why not buff those guns because I'd
rather have like I'd rather you be like
the other guns yeah both the other guys
are or nerf they might have we talked
about that you say Bob from there anyway
and because and this is like a big thing
in the Destiny community cuz everybody
screams for nerfs usually when Bungie
nurse a gun they just destroyed yeah
that's it yeah just like how we remember
thorn thorn kitty to shot yeah now it's
like yeah it's not even good no no so
like I don't want them to nerf it I
think they should just buff other guns
well that's above other guns so you can
make they can compete well right now if
I just say it's something I don't like
about destiny is that I think auto
rifles are just the most powerful gun
yeah and you can't compete you know like
pulse rifles are useless it's the same
thing that happen in just anyone
pulse rifle radio hires like you can't
it's like the only one that's good is
that vigilant's wings because you get
five shots at issues that that time war
inspires good though the iron banner
pulse good time war inspire yeah I can't
this is like a you know it doesn't count
when you say it it doesn't count I use
here I mean I you don't know you use you
have a different like you know you miss
you're good
yeah it's like everybody's using the
same like I think that they need to make
the other guns more powerful and so the
one thing I don't like too is that the
numbers the slightly they need to have
numbers instead of the bar yeah I need
to know and then I need to know like
what's the calculation here like you
know there's not a variety of weapons
like there's no there's like not many
weapons they draw you know you know you
know and I see so many weapons to choose
from you know what I think they're doing
and I've gone the einstein pulse rifle
like oh [ __ ] so many people you know
you know what I don't like it but what I
think they're doing they're trying to
cater to the casual player so like we're
hardcore like he's a Bungie lobbyist
like he's like listen guys gotta fix it
no no no no no I'm actually going
against Bungie with this comment your
[ __ ] mouth he's training for no uh
what I was saying is that they're
they're they're trying to cater to the
casual player me being a hardcore player
I don't like that at all especially when
you want people to stay playing your
game the casual players gonna halia and
then they're gonna see a weapons if they
do that well what they're doing what
they're doing and where they're cutting
everybody short right is there time
gating so what soldier so like okay
all right so remember remember the
faction rally right are you gonna give
him a new thing so I'll put it I'll put
it like this um they have this content
all already prepared already right
Bungie does the faction rally I just I
just I just know I'm not a lot reddit I
just I dread it I just I just I just
know I'm a hardcore gamer right so what
they're doing is they've had all this
content ready they're slowly leaking it
so they they give people a reason to
come back they sort of hurry up resident
rejection I know it dad I know I saw a
video on YouTube I'm telling you the the
number of players is going down and
down and and that's why that's why they
didn't you know why because they have
such they have uh such a big gamer base
from destiny one that are hardcore
players that's the only game they slam
but they're losing them because then
there's no reason to play 100 I saw the
chart I'm holding down here's another
thing there's all these times as I screw
up stuff like trials trials from last
yeah like three weeks in a row row two
weeks a row but then the other what's up
with that it was another week in the
beginning where they didn't the trial
the nine days what's it up they swim
because you could you could you can get
out of the map right sit on top of the
map yeah they have the it's already hard
enough right right oh yeah but I will
say this you know what I like I think
it's more fair cuz I never gone to the I
didn't go flawless right but I did get
seven in with you guys right and I've
never get off this one I'll tell you
this this game well I felt good about it
but is in crucible funner more balanced
more Cheetos you get a team shot you get
that you get the credit if you just like
put a bullet in their body
and you yeah you guys are call it an
assist yeah and that's Greg's main line
yeah I mean it is nice to you and
ironically it hasn't changed his Katie
at all we'll get into kiddie boring I
know this game play now I won't
he likes charges he just wrote you know
she doesn't let he done no I run less
I'd unless you been he runs less but he
hides I will I actually been shooting
but I use the guns that everybody use
yes I use them I turn the urea I don't I
know well your is like better Devils I
will I will say I won't thank you oh I
will
should I be sitting in the middle I mean
I feel no no no yeah yeah I'll take yeah
this will give heart I will give I will
give Craig little kudos cuz we almost
went flat honestly Craig should have
gone flawless twice yeah the game [ __ ]
him what happened Craig was the first
time the first time we are playing and
we get we legitimately got deed who's we
me coke arrow arrow I want to say we
play with all at one time
I gotta give a shout-out to olive what's
the solid website name I don't know
destiny will find it you put it on
another no but anyway but going back to
we were playing and we saw Jamie Lee go
Gavin was Gavin aider might have been
Gavin might have been gay rasca I've
never I've never I've never been truly
DDoS we're told I was playing with arrow
and and Craig because it happened to me
twice wait on dusty to DES yeah because
we were like I think like five or
something we were like something you
know we were doing well on one game yeah
and like we all got kicked and I'm
talking about my internet went out my
internet didn't like for lighten our my
internet went out I had to reset the
modem that was a true do you think
attack your they definitely they got our
connections and because we all got
married the IP address yeah me arrow and
code yeah all got kicked and utterly our
internet went out and I all had to
reboot our modems and stuff and try to
get back my [ __ ] was out for an hour
past how did they do that how do they do
that
I mean I don't know he does thing is
though we don't wanna give him like yes
have you guys ever seen Jay and Silent
Bob strike back
yeah when they find that people talked
about know that that's what I want to do
this guy if I knew
can you read god I'm not that angry
everybody know where you actually meet
these trolls thirteen thirteen year olds
they need some good parenting I might
get in trouble all right
gently ddosed which i which i really
upset me it's so frustrating because
you're like in the middle of game and
that's trials so you know like you're
putting in a lot of energy and effort
and sort of get kicked like that was it
the last round you know I did we were
really close yeah we were really close
and then and then another time Pikachu
got kicked we're playing a Pikachu okay
so please - and you know we were what it
was me
meskhi all imagine me and PU and peek -
so we were playing we weren't taking it
seriously like we'll see how far we get
we got two six wins we needed one six
and one yes six - no and I'm like I need
to go forward seven we're on our last
game our last game so hard now this is
where tears dogger it and is this where
peek I'm gonna call Pikachu out a little
bit because I'm still skeptical I still
want pink I think he bailed
but Pikachu started this card with us he
had one loss when we started winning and
realizing we were getting closer to
flawless he wouldn't shut like Oh Craigs
gonna go flawless and I know Craig's
gonna go flawless and I'm not
and then ironically the last game he
doesn't get dropped from the party it
just says at the bottom
Pikachu left fireteam on our last game
he left the team it's possible and we
lost and then he he literally got back
in the party right after the game oh
sorry my [ __ ] disconnected guys and I
was like what happens when what I mean
that's a baller as well on his
[Applause]
[Music]
completely but what happens when someone
leaves like that is it to beef before it
was three verse four and it we were it
was already a good team it was already a
good it was already a know one guy oh
you're so weird yeah we got fun yeah we
got [ __ ] so that was it so my two
times trying to get flawless never no no
there is another one there's another one
where oh we did it in a reset we did it
and it resets so Craig couldn't even go
so they're like literally it's supposed
to reset it like 2:00 a.m. or something
you know whatever the reset is their
trials and it reset like half an hour
early or like an hour no I think it was
I think it was like 20 minutes early
they're trying to we were close on six
and zero again and then like literally
they're like well let's go to the tower
before it resets we left the game and
the town it was that you know that a
spider the spire I don't like the supers
I don't like I don't like how long they
take my storm trance gonna kill anyone
even though that's because that's
because you're spoiled with that destiny
one [ __ ] storm tracks and the shadow
shot the shadow shun doesn't kill people
and that [ __ ] that sucks that's the
worst oh it doesn't kill people it
doesn't go well the first one you did
melted are you yeah aren't writers serum
like the arts are sir
what the [ __ ] is that arc spider thing
yeah I mean either the dawn blade like
it doesn't you can't ain't like you'll
be you'll be doing it and then somebody
just kind of moving you know that's like
sunsinger sword I think I think the Dom
blades kind of hard to use but I you
could do to hone in better honestly
you're you put and honestly that super
[ __ ] me up more than Donnelly yeah
because they're always super [ __ ]
super hot even if I possible even when I
pop a golden I'm so used to looking left
to right but I do like to sick shot
Golden Gun cuz I'm not good with it so I
need I need like yeah they need a nerf
ability
yeah no no they do why they why I need a
nerf the Galatian you know I know I know
there's no way to compete against you
know what I'm saying
super though supposed to kill me yeah
but do when I do my thing my storm
transit I don't kill you that's the
funny that's a funny thing because I
need a link the oh yes because the only
super that [ __ ] me up when I'm going I
need a storm collar because the [ __ ]
are blinking all over the place yeah not
only that I need a blink not only that
not only that with the Golden Gun I got
to get a headshot to kill you with one
shot if I shoot you in the body it
doesn't kill you I don't want to slow no
but you might have been hurt before
someone else may have shot you and then
you got shot with going again alright
can I go can I say one of my beeps is
choice I don't like that they took away
choice especially in crucible you mean
for the trees I can't choose the random
I would pick a sprite like I wanted to
do this strike right right why took away
the choice and I think that's a bad
thing for any game you want to leave
players with choice once again and I'm
not a lobbyist their time dating and I
don't like it so what there's like a
movie coming in today
hey guys look they got me character
they've already said they're bringing
private matches early next year so
they've already got this [ __ ] ready what
they're doing is they're trying to milk
it but what they need they need to just
start putting it all out let us just
complain I don't like the map selection
to I don't like some of those maps man
like the one in the snow is I'm going
shop I might as like it's like Bozek the
bolsa yeah the iron dire manner
yeah for a week later there what I wish
they would do is like your miter didn't
work for a week like I said you know no
- for a week yeah that's not [ __ ] your
mind no I have another scout rifle he
used call to serve I liked that one was
my favorite for a knight's good but uh
what I mean the choice bought bothers me
and and here's another thing like I look
at it like I look at fighting games like
when you have a fighting game the first
game always has like 20 fighters
then the next game has 35 that's water
and and destiny should have gone from
like the first game or you had all these
modes and all these games and added to
it yeah and instead what they did is
they paired down they took out a lot of
stuff but they [ __ ] us in destiny won
anyway when they took away year there's
no way your one stuff right then it
promised all these other guns and they
never felt that like if I go to my
destiny one right now there are still
exotic slots that I don't have true I
don't have open I never got if so many
guns I've never got a veteran I never
got that that's actually a good thing
because that makes you want to play to
get them right but this game I think
I've seen every you know what I think
the problem was to I think they've made
exotics a big part of the leveling up
system because the exotics always drop
higher so they've made exotics drop more
frequent so you can get your character
up but then once you get the exotic like
we said we you got the exotic there's
really nothing more to grind for we
don't have news like there's no
incentive yes to a character to was a
specific warlock guy or the till a lock
it's a warlock gun so I just so then
therefore like when you're playing with
that cuz what I've been doing is I went
to app I just keep moving nine same guns
over so it's like it's kind of like
Sirius radio station or something where
you're only you only listening like
three stations yeah well the hunter has
that once orb that's kind of well they
have a sword yeah yeah the hundreds a
samurai sword
you never say they do yeah it's a less
it's not exotic it's like only hunters
could use it as a sword but do you hate
going against somewhere using I hate I
hate going against him baked you just
you're dead what you know you could jump
over here you can you could you could
block to ding-ding yeah they could
deflect your bullet um they could do
that in destiny one though too
but what what the
the night stalkers and visibility that's
probably one of the best the swords in
destiny you know you've been killed a
lot by that [ __ ] and destiny won the
invisibility you could still see it not
only that it wouldn't take a my sister
way so if you saw the outline your gun
would still follow in this one all the
aim assists gone I know my yo-yo get hit
you can't last night I was planning
there was a guy hiding in Horace waiting
for everybody run by and then just
sorting us and always hob would love
that Bob yeah you're just spitting up
like a five-year steam just I don't know
I can't I can't
well all away what just stays in there
oh it just contains and you know what it
is here he is his Asian face has no
expression
we always go off just for you know but
that being said I mean so I mean I think
there's a lot of disappointments now
they're gonna have DLC so hopefully
that'll fix some yeah but they're gonna
lose people it's gonna be too late Craig
three years in on this game now that's
before but it is your four but it feels
like it feels like year one of destiny
to you know it doesn't feel like you're
for it feels like exactly but that's
what I feel I gotta be honest in destiny
one there was a lot of people that
weren't that interested for a while and
then as DLC came a point why isn't there
more factions why is it just the three
right I don't think they should have
twenty factions you could join not just
dead or broke in future work I mean if
you go to the story then it's like you
know and what they do everything we got
[ __ ] on destiny a lot let's I think
we should all come in things we really
like yeah Bungie we love your game yeah
I'm still playing with you Greg you guys
like playing on those on the thing for
the factions though they you know one
thing they did do is add the specific
gear for the planets and they call that
faction gear like if you look at the
armor and yeah and the thing is that I
guess oh we play this game so much like
I don't even want to tell you guys how
many days I already had when we started
apart
you were three or five yeah just
starting there like I don't take you're
a character I'm like how the [ __ ] is he
three or five all day I mean as much
soon as we give it for playability we
play this [ __ ] out of that we do so like
I wish I um but like if they keep it if
they keep refreshing the next podcast
we're gonna if they if they keep
refreshing like the stuff in our
grievances if they keep refreshing the
stuff you get a like the planets and
stuff like that that would be dope
because then we'll have the three
factions you'll have the four planets
what's four planets right yeah four
planets and can the lost sectors this is
what I don't like a bird sector yes is
when I should be special right oh I
discovered this lost sector when you
beat that boss you should get something
dope so let it be like something harder
to be and Luyden and also heroic public
events - yeah like you should at least
get a lot areas at first it was felt
more glimmer like 30,000 glimmer or
something crazy the first time you
played them it did feel good because you
would get a legendary rattle Olaf and
you're at a low level but now that you
get high there's just no incentive and
that's the brawl and that's that's like
my feeling when they when they explained
it is I felt like the law sectors were
gonna be like World of Warcraft kind of
like a super hard boss you had to get
your team ready right right Forge or
something yeah
yeah all right well going back to what
do we like so what do we like you like
playing with your friends Griffin what
do you like I guess I like that same
thing but I guess I do like that this
time if you want to play so if you want
to play solo there is a lot to do there
is a lot to do and then and when it
refreshes it's always like I like
pressing the left trigger and seeing all
these little yeah yeah you know it's you
know I don't well another dope thing is
I like the shaders the variety of you
can change you can make yourself your
guns look different than like I like I
have a heroes it look different than
yours I like that
yes but one thing I still don't like but
I know we're doing positive but I had to
just go back to this is I still don't
like the fact that you know you need
it's hard to do the raids it's hard to
do this one stupid raid which I still
haven't finished I haven't done we're
gonna get you guys yeah I haven't but
the point is like it's still like you
have to like find six people and I go
yeah well and we haven't tried none of
us have tried the guided games because
first off when I heard those aren't
doing too well well they were 45 minute
weights when they first came out and I
was like dude no I don't want to wait an
hour to get with random people and then
you know if you get with random people
and then you know how that goes some
ones are another thing I don't like
about the PvP element is every time you
play you're playing against a stacked
team I like why can't they split up
it's you're playing against like like a
group like us well but that's good I
want to play by myself
I'm gonna go against the stack do this
goes back and they're they're playing
like doing teamwork shots and that goes
back to choices like I think you'd enjoy
sysm on who you can play and things I
wish there's lobbies were so positive
yeah so let's do what do you think is
positive [ __ ] nothing
the multiplayer I don't mind it's not as
bad weighted and feel like it's more
quicker and it's a little more
streamlined it's like I could get kills
and it's like I'm not gonna get
absolutely demolished when I do start
scream atras they'll toss in a tougher
challenge I like that where it's like
I'll win three matches and we'll be like
okay we're destroying and then like that
second a match it's like all right we
destroyed by like ten points and then by
that third match they've matched us with
a team that's like either good or a
little bit better and then it's like
more of a challenge so it makes me try
to it makes me play a little better or
it challenges me to play a little bit
better yeah I what I like about it it's
better I mean most people know I like
PvP more than anything so like what I
like about it is I it kinda takes me
back to halo because I loved halo halo
is my first there's my first-person
shooter so like it kind of went back to
that and it kinda resembles like the
time to kill and like you like you were
saying in a different way Joyce is what
what they said and I agree is like when
I get into a gunfight in destiny - I
have the option of am I gonna stay here
am I gonna try and win this gunfight or
did this guy get the jump on me I'm
gonna get the [ __ ] out of here because
the time to kill is a lot higher so I
get to make those choices where you
could be a really good player and if
you're playing against those teams
they're really good like you wouldn't
especially trials you wouldn't have the
option to even run you're dead instantly
and stuck with a stuff it's sticking
your name with me with crazy aim assist
you're [ __ ] dead so I like those
changes they made I like that they don't
have all this one-hit-kill garbage
shotguns you start with four rounds and
you just got a team of three guys
running around shotgun and my sniper
said I didn't like people camping with
sniper oh yeah yeah and the thing is
there's people bitching about that cuz
no one uses snipers no one's a knife or
snipers are good when I do yeah in pub
with power ammo because here's the thing
if you're a skilled hand right everybody
uses everybody uses rocket rocket
launchers that's one shot so shots so so
with rocket launchers you get two shots
you get two kills maybe if you get lucky
and they're all clumped up you get a
bunch but there's but you know I get six
rounds with a sniper I can take out four
dudes you know so I can't do camp when
you get the ammo every once in a while
but what I like about it what I like
especially with a sniper is it's a
team-based game right so if you got a
good team they're all running together
shot so I'd like to use the sniper on
distance or
which is the old shores of time when
they all go to be and I got that I'm all
the way across in that little sniper
lane I know because they never expect it
and I can you know what no one yeah we
should all you slap rifles I also don't
like grenades though I don't like the
grenade I don't like the grenade changes
yeah I do
well the poster days still do post names
great it's just like the just mean one
but the tripmine should do better damage
by the French Rene should do better
damage you should doesn't do anything
when you use the solar now I I agree I
agree though because the fusion the well
I think the fusion should be nerfed into
the ground and I'll tell you why because
same with the shoulder charge they're
making it Craig their hold on and I'm
touching on it the reason they did it is
once again you can't spam one-hit-kill
abilities shoulder charge in its heyday
in the end like year one destiny one
yeah it the aim-assist on it and it's a
one-hit kill it's not it really not
skillful all you gotta see is a guy I
think the problem is not the shoulder
Church make that be a one-hit kill but
if you have a full melee bar that should
be a one-hit kill like I I think it's
useless like it like right you need a
two or three even if you have a whole
bar and you hit somebody you still gotta
hit them free time but what's the point
of having that warlock mailing okay I'll
hit him right then they'll melee me back
but let's so the so you'll have to like
press right away to get the timing on
your next one
but listen we were just talking about
swords right people wait around corners
with the sword waiting for people to
come by someone hit kill if somebody if
you get a one hit kill now way too weak
and then and then people read that and
then they use their armor mod to
recharge their melee
they're gonna wait behind stuff melee
somebody wait till they're melee combat
here's waiting for a star charge boom
wait oh can't do this
with a shoulder charge run sword your
one hit kills they shouldn't be they
should be two hit kills because that's
the only weapon in the whole game
besides one rocket launcher rocket
launcher that's a one-hit kill but what
they're trying to do what they're trying
to do is make it so you have to make a
choice you know that that guy's weak and
to get the jump up I'm gonna use my
shoulder charge they're they're making
it so you have to use it at the right
time not just I'm gonna spam this really
really good you see somebody's power
okay you see their health if you not
waiting on in the crucible you can see
somebody's health yeah three minutes
let's see if you can do it using
grenades I'm gonna yo and we talked
about it when we took you flawless that
last destiny one that guy was not good
at all but he literally wrecked it
because he would wait and just stick
people and they would in it to lay long
yeah the the aim assist on stick
grenades is still ridiculously high it's
still ridiculously high so if you if you
give someone well but even let me say
what I don't like about the shoulder
charge now is like you hit someone what
it does is it helps them because it
pushes them back into a perfect position
yeah they kill you when you're gone yeah
you know I know about shoulder charge so
you know all these guys can agree all
they want I got the highest KD
let's go back to close reference right
now yes so let me get my positive in the
game looks beautiful oh it looks
beautiful
and the other thing I like is I think
the single-player campaign was a lot
better there's at least a storyline and
you get to know the characters a little
more in the in the tower and so there's
a little more to going so I think all
that's really positive and I think I
think the team play is positive yeah
that like you know as a lot of its team
shots a lot of its really playing
together yeah
so I think that part you know I wish
each character had its own story though
like the hunter had a different story
from the warlock at the time you know
and in they do they just didn't touch on
they didn't touch on one minute we got
one minute
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]